Speaker 1: Radical, repugnant. Republican
Congresswoman Lauren Boebert bizarrely was
praying in the Capitol Rotunda. Now, as
many of you know, I am not a Christian,
so I've wondered for a long time when
people say they were pleading the blood
of Jesus. What the hell does that
mean? I'm wondering, is this video
Lauren Boebert pleading the blood of Jesus?
You tell me what's going on here. Take a look.
Speaker 7: Thank you for your side. Jesus.
We come only by the blood of Jesus is only
that blood that grants us access into the
holy of holies, into your presence. God,
we thank you so much for your goodness. It is your
goodness that leads men to repentance. That causes
men to change their mind about you and God to see
a different side of your Holiness. Yeah, God, we
love you because you first loved us. Jesus, Thank
you for your redemptive work. It was complete. It
was whole. There was nothing missing. There
was nothing lacking. There's nothing that you
left out. Jesus. Thank you, Jesus. You paid the
price for each and every one of us. You went to
hell in our place, and you rose again victorious.
And when you were seated at the right hand of the
father on high, you did not leave us alone.
Speaker 1: How is this not mental illness?
Speaker 7: You sent us another time.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I think you get the
idea. Nothing makes me respect religious people
less than when they orchestrate conspicuous public
prayers for publicity. Genuinely. And by the
way, listen, I don't care what Matthew says,
but in Matthew six six, it does say when
you pray, go into your room, close the door,
and pray to your father, who is unseen. Then
your father, who sees what is done in secret,
will reward you. Not that I care what is in
Matthew six six, but if Lauren Boebert claims to,
shouldn't she be following that dictate
and not orchestrating this pathetic public
stunt anyway? Is that pleading the blood of
Jesus? Maybe somebody can tell me what it is.